on l'appelle la perle de l'adriatique
inscrites depuis 1978 au patrimoine
mondial de l'unesco
pourtant il ya quatorze ans la cité
historique de dubrovnik a bien failli
être rayée de la carte
les roquettes tirées par la marine
yougoslave passe par dessus le fort
saint-jean pour faire mouche dans le
vieux-port du produit un obus toutes les
minutes pendant près d'une meilleure
image les dégâts sont considérables
non pas en tant que la volonté de trois
c'est un des fils et des séquelles de la
crise comme ardiden dix ans après la fin
du conflit en ex-yougoslavie
voici le nouveau visage de la ques un
patrimoine entièrement restauré une
cause film acculé et un ciel bleu azur
autant dire tous les ingrédients se sert
de ce quine annuel y aura des touristes
on aurait là vous irez cela et perdra ne
savais que ça dure on n'a pas parlé à la
croatie la guerre s'est achevée dans 19
centrales on a aimé vpourquoi vers les
jo comme l'à une fois l'ebit était
brésilien dani alves s'est alors petit à
petit les touristes sont venus des pays
de l'est à bord et suède allemagne
notamment
l'an dernier l'union d'étrangers alizaï
la croatie ce pas mieux il s'agit d'une
première
quatre cent chez les gars beaucoup
changé
moi qui vivent et l'église est ouverte
où la messe chaque jour j'avais envie de
visiter vraiment parce que par exemple
double mixte une ville extraordinaire
beaucoup de touristes dit que nous avons
un très beau bâtiment et qu'ils admirent
vraiment notre les pumas ce patrimoine
l'entité de nos villes en deux ans
l'intérêt très relative des français
pour la 3 6 est mué en un véritable
engouement
à tel point que les croates eux mêmes
ont dû s'adapter zohra lui a pris des
cours à l'alliance française
je n'ai agréable avec nous et je pense
que mon ballon un fait avec
mais notre collège
certes elle est aujourd'hui la priorité
du gouvernement croate c'est d'améliorer
les structures d'accueil en contrôlant
entre autres les chambres chez
l'habitant et en modernisant certains
hôtels
pas question en revanche de construire
tous azimuts le tourisme de masse n'est
pas le bienvenu sur la riviera croate